you know in the last segment your you
know your there's a lot you get worked
up about you know and you've always been
that way I've known you a long time you
get worked up about studying happy
universe for he was like things were
better when I was three days my tunas
guilty as charged
yeah so here's the thing here's the
thing are you now that you're playing
master square garden you got all these
fans you're extremely successful
comedian are you able to enjoy your
success now are you able to just have
some fun that's a fact that you're a
success yes I enjoy but I still you know
the bane of my existence is I let little
things bother me downloading new
operating systems will just you know I
bring a lot of tension into the house
according to my wife yeah yeah one thing
I've noticed we're always working on me
you know like my wife is evidently some
completed work like under museum glass
I'm like that building that has scaffold
she is she's a saint for putting up with
me I I know but like my latest thing
that's driving me nuts is I spent 20
years in the back of the plane getting
treated like an animal and I finally
worked my way up to the front of the
plane Group one which means you get to
board like it's your plane right you
just you get to board
yes yeah you sit in a chair that's the
size for a human being there's a place
for your bag yep yep right you get a
little hot towel and all and then the
second I get that all of a sudden now
there's like these 20 groups that are
like pre-boarding now like half the
plane qualifies and they're getting on
and I just sit there just like losing my
[ __ ] you know it'll start softly it's
just like anybody in uniform anybody in
military so it's like alright alright
but after like the 20th guy you just
start being like if you've seen action
[Applause]
anybody with kids
anybody with disabilities and they just
say anybody with a red shirt hey it's
Tony Tuesday at one time I saw this guy
get on the plane okay he wasn't in
uniform he didn't have kids he had all
his limbs he wasn't limping she didn't
have a cop he just walked on the plane
it's like I always hated the anxiety of
being in the back of the plane I just
remember like the worst is whenever you
would get your seat and you'd sit there
know about ready to close the door
and you'd have that empty seat next to
you last like a poor man's first class
you're like oh [ __ ] I'll bring the
armrest up I can actually be great then
all of a sudden some fat bastard you
like Quint at the end of Jaws like slide
I swear to god this is all true this
dude got on he was so fat he was sitting
next to me I was literally next to him
and behind him smaller and he like
folded his arm and his lat came out like
like a jealous old western saloon thing
so yeah so yeah that that motivates you
to try to get to these layers 20 years
you work your way up to the front and
now still they won't let you that fat
guys considered disabled because he
can't stop so he gets on look at me
groaning 90% of the world is starving to
death
[Applause]
whoa okay what could you do could you do
anything then could you get on the plane
is there anything you could do I imagine
there's something that I could be doing
there's always something that I could be
doing that's what I've learned being
married you know what you should have
done it this way
I'm sorry that definitely is why mer
what right now playing in the loop on
what am i doing now you know this is the
thing you know what it kills me it's
just like if I could just fix my temper
my wife she'd have nothing on me yeah
nothing on me I worked my ass off and
make a great living I like doing the
dishes I'm a great dad all she has on me
is just it's just I don't know like oh
my overall vibe all she has on you is -
your overall personality and violence of
who you are is the owner there but I was
this guy when she met me yeah exactly
like I changed you always always
flipping up
were you sleeping out the day like when
you met did you flip out and would you
believe that she told me to go see that
movie monster remember that movie with
Charlie Theron yeah yeah yeah and
everybody was saying how I owe my god it
was unbelievable it wasn't like ah
somebody shoved a tuna fish sandwich up
my ass and I confused people with food
so I like did he make like a big excuse
for
yeah she was a psycho killing people and
she should have died but I'm like
watching it feeling guilt somehow our
fault why would having a tuna fish
sandwich shoved up your butt make it
equal because another man did it first
so if you equate it I don't know sex
with food I figure I figured out the
idea but uh is she laughed when I said
it she was dying laughing and kind of
saw my point and I always hate when she
says to me she'd just be like you know I
just don't see what weight is that
coming from where is that coming from he
says like honey how many childhood
stories do I have to tell you before you
follow the breadcrumbs to this psycho
that you're married I mean did you ever
take a psychology class like you didn't
see this coming right that's what it is
it's not that she says that I'm a jerk
it's just the nerve to be surprised
[Laughter]
all right I wish we had more time
good God all right I feel like I do I
help you at all but getting all this no
cathartic it's cathartic cuz I'm gonna
go home she's not gonna watch this she's
over what I guess there's no one just
she's not gonna watch she's not gonna
watch it yeah yeah you can see bill on
his latest nationwide tour 50 and he's
starting to mellow I swear to God I am
I'm getting the twinkle in my eye back
at the TD at the TD Garden Boston on
October 5th and Madison Square Garden
Wow on Wednesday November 7 for more
cities and dates thank you go to
Bilborough
dot-com Bilbo
[Applause]
you